Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
Wandavision episode 9 post credit scene video all
about what's going on with wanda during doctor
strange two we know a lot about what's going
on with that movie already the characters that
they're doing and now because of Wandavision we
have an idea for what the plot actually is so if
you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos also be doing full episodes for
falcon and winter soldier that's going to start
in a couple weeks too careful for spoilers for
everything that happened on Wandavision obviously
if you haven't seen the episodes but there are two
post-credits scenes in the Wandavision finale so
it's actually a mid credit scene and then there's
an actual post credit scene if you want to get
really technical about it i'm mostly going to
focus on that doctor strange 2 post credit scene
in this video but at the end of Wandavision wanda
fully accepts her new identity as the scarlet
witch takes all of her chaos magic power back
from act of the hardness that she stole and takes
most if not all of agatha harkness's magic from
her like you see all that purple energy flowing
into her along with her red chaos magic energy
then after going final boss form scarlet witch
she says her goodbyes to vision billy and tommy
the twins knowing she might never see them again
but kind of hopeful that she will so even if you
don't include the actual post-credit scene reveal
the writers kind of left the door open for all
three of them to return in the future with the
lines of dialogue that they all went out on
like she keeps saying family is forever she
said that line a couple times during the series no
matter what so that's like kevin feige saying yes
things are going to get really twisty with this
but they're totally coming back in the future
and we all expected billy and tommy to come back
and then to do a version of their comic book story
for young avengers stuff in the future it's more
a question of how not if they do it but she flies
off in her new comic book costume full-blown comic
book scarlet witch with the darkhold to learn more
about her chaos magic powers and her role as
the scarlet witch of the mcu because the way
they explain it is basically a title learn what
the darkhold says about her and investigate the
claims that act of the hardness was making
about wanda unleashing something terrible
there were a couple lines of dialogue that akka
had while they were battling each other saying
you have no idea what you've done you're going
to need my help to deal with what's to come more
on that in a second too there are a couple clues
inside the actual darkhold book itself when you
look at the pages but in the actual post-credits
scene it's implied that she's in the mcu version
of the mountains of wondergore the place where her
mother actually gave birth to her in the comics
and a lot of you've also asked if this scene is
actually meant to be a real scene from the doctor
strange 2 movie like they just clipped it right
out of doctor strange two and tacked it onto the
end of Wandavision they've done that before but
it's rare the best examples of that are the doctor
strange thor ragnarok post credit scene that was
an actual scene from ragnarok that taika wattidi
filmed himself even though scott derrickson
filmed the doctor strange movie and they just
sort of tagged it on to the end of the doctor
strange film and before that they did kind of
the same thing with the ant-man post-credits scene
for captain america civil war with the bucky scene
it was a scene they clipped right out of captain
america civil war and just tagged onto the end of
the ant-man movie but for the most part the marvel
movie post-credits scenes aren't meant to be
actual footage from the movies that they're
teasing but as a lot of you detected as this
scene is happening they're playing the doctor
strange theme song in the background just to let
you know that this is meant to be a doctor strange
2 teaser i know a lot of people were wondering why
benedict cumberbatch didn't actually show up in
the Wandavision finale even if it was only to be
on screen for a couple seconds i think when they
were actually filming this scene for wandavision
they weren't quite ready to start filming doctor
strange too so they didn't know quite what they
were going to do with that movie yet they were
still working on the script and also some people
have pointed out that when they were filming
Wandavision because of the pandemic because of
the virus benedict cumberbatch was literally
trapped in like new zealand or australia like
he couldn't travel for a while and they filmed a
lot of Wandavision in los angeles so even if they
had wanted benedict cumberbatch to show up they
probably would not have been able to do that so my
assumption is that we won't see this scene during
doctor strange too but the other really important
easter egg here the mountains of wondergore
is this is the place where the god of chaos
cathode wrote the darkhold book that she's reading
from in this scene it's also the place where the
high evolutionaries base was located for those of
you that are hoping that they do him at some point
his real name is herbert wyndham because he
started out as a human man there was an easter
egg for him in guardians of the galaxy vol 2.
berhert the planet they went to is basically
an anagram for herbert there's a lot of theories
about them trying to tie the high evolutionary to
rocket raccoon's backstory so we'll see if we wind
up seeing that character eventually the connection
back to scarlet witch though is that scarlet
witch's mother fled to the high evolutionary's
castle in the one dagora mountains to give birth
to her and when she was doing that the elder god
Chthon imbued wanda with her potential for magic
in a lot of her power that was all the chaos magic
that act of the harkness was referring to the way
the Wandavision episodes changed that backstory
just for the mcu a little bit as they say that she
had only barely tapped into her latent abilities
when she was a child and when she encountered the
mind stone it then amplified her abilities off the
charts to cosmic levels so she would have always
been very powerful had she trained as a witch it's
just the mind stone turned her into the mythical
one true scarlet witch that the darkhold spoke of
so it's a funny backdoor time travel explainer
because in the flashbacks we saw that the mind
stone gave scarlet witch a vision of her future
when she went final boss formed scarlet witch
and now we know from the darkhold that
it spoke of her and foretold her future
as the scarlet witch the whole thing about her
future is the darkhold is saying that she is
supposed to destroy the world that'll get into the
plot of doctor strange too i'll talk about that in
a second we're going to get into a lot of time
travel story during the loki series so they'll
probably explain a little bit more about how time
travel actually works in the mcu they kind of
touched on that briefly during avengers end game
the way they set that up is the whole idea is
that you can't change your own past you can only
create alternate timelines that's why they got
into that whole big explainer with the ancient one
talking about how the infinity stones control the
flow of time and you also alter the flow of time
create more branch timelines when you try to steal
infinity stones from the past but just to be
clear with scarlet witch's powers even before
she had her power upgraded she was always able to
cast spells without using incantations like agatha
harkness says that was in the flashbacks with
the stark tech bomb the way they explained that
is that she used a hex spell without speaking any
words as a child just on instinct to stop the bomb
from exploding so she was born super powerful
already but like i said in the comics that's
because Chthon this god of chaos imbued her with
all this power when she was a baby but as we see
wanda now after what seems like a small time jump
no idea exactly how much time has gone by she's
seen astral projecting herself studying from the
darkhold while also just hanging out drinking tea
getting all that fresh wundigor mountain air just
enjoying some alone time when all of a sudden
she hears billy and tommy's screams for help from
another dimension however you want to think about
it another plane of existence the way the mcu
talks about that though like heaven hell those
concepts it's all just alternate dimensions the
very scientific way they explain how magic works
in the mcu during the doctor strange movie they
kind of did that during the first thor movie as
well like it seems like magic but really it's just
highly advanced science that you don't understand
yet so like the astral plane when you're asked
for projecting or when it seems like you're astral
projecting that's just another alternate dimension
that exists overlapping with our dimension so it
seems like you're flying around like a ghost when
really you're kind of in two places at the same
time and i know there were a lot of questions
about this too how was wanda's physical body
still alert walking around interacting with her
environment while she was astral projecting i
think that's just them paying off the idea
that she's supposed to be more powerful than
doctor strange like agatha harkness says per the
darkhold more powerful than the sorcerer's supreme
when you saw doctor strange asked for projecting
during the original doctor strange movie you just
see his physical body go inert while he's flying
around as for what happened to billy and tommy
like why are they screaming out asking for help
if it's true that marvel really is using all this
scarlet witch chaos magic darkhold easter eggs
to set up the god of chaos c'thon then he would
be the person responsible for what's happening
to billy and tommy so early prediction they're
just referencing the mephisto parts of wanda's
backstory with the twins but swapping in Chthon
like he's messing with wanda because she used
chaos magic to create them powered with the
background cosmic radiation the same energy as
the infinity stones and he controls chaos magic
he is the source of that magic and the larger
threat that agatha harkness was talking about
in the finale is both literally and metaphorically
chaos like wanda will bring true chaos to the mcu
in messing with large-scale chaos magic while
she's trying to find and save billy and tommy
in this whole idea of her unleashing chaos on the
mcu is the future that the darkhold is foretelling
for her it is your destiny to destroy the world
in doing all these things the title of the movie
doctor strange two multiverse of madness also
implies an epic level of chaos anyway in what's
a better follow-up premise for the mcu after the
infinity saga than chaos coming to the mcu like
thanos was all about bringing this grand sinister
concept of order his order to the universe
iron man snapped him out of existence so in the
absence in the vacuum of order there is chaos
flooding into the mcu metaphorically and literally
so now it makes more sense why doctor strange 2 is
one of the most important marvel phase 4 movies
that doesn't mean that c'thon or the god of chaos
however you want to think about him is like the
next thanos level big bad but it does seem based
on these easter eggs like that's what they're
implying so presumably after this wanda starts
actually looking for her children and eventually
doctor strange learns about what's going on with
the darkhold the hex and wanda's chaos magic and
then he steps in if she were going to seek his
help she probably would have done it already like
this post-credit scene makes it seem like she's
been going at solo since the end of Wandavision in
early theory just based on what they set up in the
Wandavision finale and all the foreshadowing and
the more obvious clues and connections to doctor
strange too wanda's whole motivation right now is
in learning more about chaos magic and saving the
twins she's already shown that she has no problem
going completely off the rails going way overboard
in everything she does with chaos magic so now
that she has one of the most dangerous powerful
books of magic in existence with more information
than she's probably ready for she uses the book
the darkhold to try and find the twins in that
inadvertently sets off the actual plot of doctor
strange too with the multiverse being engulfed in
total chaos like there's some scene at the very
beginning of doctor strange too where wanda does
something terrible on accident with chaos magic in
pursuit of the twins and that sets everything off
also talking more about multiverse foreshadowing
and easter eggs in the darkhold book when agatha
harkness is reading from it during the finale
notice these two pages here that it opens up too
on the left page you see what looks like multiple
different worlds which i think is the multiverse
connection to scarlet witch and her chaos magic
because on the right page she starts talking about
wanda reading from her backstory talking about
what the darkhold says about her you assume
then that this drawing is supposed to be of
the scarlet witch but it also kind of looks
like a depiction of cathome with the tentacles
coming out of his head like this doesn't look like
wanda's hair given that his name is very hard to
pronounce it's always possible that marvel also
changes his character a little for the mcu like
they just refer to him as the god of chaos or the
elder god so far they've said that scarlet witch
is one of the most important characters during
marvel phase four and i'm assuming this is why
because she's so deeply connected to the
concept of chaos in the mcu chaos magic
literal chaos the forces of chaos and because of
her connection to the infinity stones she's also
a good bridge between the infinity saga of movies
thanos the last really big bad in the new big bad
of marvel phase 4. just talking more about the
doctor strange 2 movie what we know right now is
that obviously they're going to introduce america
chavez's miss america character she's one of the
many new young avengers characters in addition to
wiccan and speed that they're introducing in the
new movies and disney plus series her big power
is opening portals to other dimensions and she
got her powers in another alternate dimension
that exists outside of normal space-time in the
presence of the demogurge and that's the sentient
godlike life force that created the elder gods
like Chthon so she also has a connection to the
concept of chaos in the mcu and it's a multiverse
movie she's a multiverse traveler baron mordo is
also back too and his big thing you remember in
the doctor strange post credit scene was getting
rid of magic users he keeps talking about the
bill coming due there has to be a consequence
for people using magic or misusing magic think
about how he would react when he learns about
what wanda has done with chaos magic in the hex
he would probably really really hate her but we'll
probably get the first doctor strange 2 trailer in
the fall that's usually the schedule marvel is on
when it comes to dropping trailers so even though
we have falcon and winter soldier episodes coming
up obviously i'll be doing videos for that we'll
get more information about doctor strange too for
the next couple of months while they continue to
film the movie but post all your theories and your
predictions in the comments below how do you think
that wanda is connected to the big bad of marvel
phase four and who do you think that big bad is
there's a couple more Wandavision videos that
i'm working on and then eventually i'll start
doing more falcon and winter soldier videos there
are a couple new trailers that they've dropped as
well so i'll try to get those videos out as
fast as possible make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss any of
those everyone click here for my full Wandavision
episode 9 finale video in easter eggs and click
here for that brand new thor 4 love and thunder
first look video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!